All right. All right. Bryce, Bryce fancy. Everyone knows Bryce fancy. All right. The guy with a sweatband and a Heather Gray t-shirt wants to tell us what's fancy and what's not. All right, Bryce. We got it. I might make that the cold open on every single one. welcome to adsp the podcast episode 117 recorded on february 16th 2023 my name is connor and today with my co-host bryce we talked to zach lane about a plethora of topics including object-oriented programming c++ containers apis the elements of programming, and so much more. This is part one of probably a four or five-part interview series. All right, well, we should introduce Zach. Works at Cadence Systems, senior principal engineer, I believe. More importantly, or I don't know, maybe it's more important, maybe it's not.
好的。好的。Bryce，Bryce Fancy。大家都知道 Bryce Fancy。好的。这个戴着运动发带、穿着浅灰色 T 恤的家伙想告诉我们什么很 fancy，什么不 fancy。好了，Bryce。我们知道了。我可能会把这作为每一集的开场白。欢迎来到 adsp 播客第 117 集，录制于 2023 年 2 月 16 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，我们采访了 Zack Lane，探讨了大量话题，包括面向对象编程、C++ 容器、API、《编程要素》（Elements of Programming）等等。这是可能由四到五部分组成的采访系列的第一部分。好吧，我们应该介绍一下 Zack。他在 Cadence Systems 工作，高级首席工程师，我想是的。更重要地，或者我不知道，也许更重要，也许不重要。
He's a member of the ISO C++ committee, author of multiple Boost libraries. We've met before multiple times. And I was just at your LinkedIn profile. I had no, do you live in Austin? Yeah. Man, that's a missed opportunity. I was just in Austin. You were just in Austin?
他是 ISO C++ 委员会成员，多个 Boost 库的作者。我们以前见过好多次。我刚才看了看你的 LinkedIn 个人资料。我完全不知道，你住在奥斯汀吗？是的。天哪，这真是一个错失的机会。我刚刚去过奥斯汀。你刚刚去过奥斯汀？
In January. Yeah, for my favorite race of all the races I've ever raced, which is like probably, I don't know, 30, 40, 50. The 3M Austin Half Marathon. It happened on January 22nd, and it's a great race because it's mostly downhill. Those are my favorite kind of races. I always feel I perform my best when I'm running downhill. And yeah, I was there for a few days. Austin's got to be, it might be my number one favorite American city.
在 1月。是的，为了我所有跑过的比赛中最喜欢的一场，大概有，我不知道，30、40、50场吧。3M 奥斯汀半程马拉松。它在 1 月 22 日举行，这是一场很棒的比赛，因为大部分都是下坡路。那是我最喜欢的比赛。我总觉得当我跑下坡时我表现得最好。是的，我在那里呆了几天。奥斯汀一定，它可能是我最喜欢的美国城市第一名。
Really? Definitely better than New York. Oh, okay. Well, now we've got a problem here. It's got that downtown vibe, but also like five minutes from downtown. Yeah, it's better than Nework if you want to get like hit by a car in austin i think you're thinking of houston yeah i know he's a get by a car in houston there's a thing when you cross the street in houston people speed up when they see you
真的吗？绝对比纽约好。哦，好吧。嗯，现在我们这里有个问题。它既有市中心的氛围，而且离市中心也就五分钟路程。是的，如果你想在奥斯汀被车撞的话，它比纽约好。我觉得你想的是休斯顿。对，我知道，在休斯顿被车撞是一回事，你在休斯顿过马路时，人们看到你反而会加速。
because they're like you're in my lane get on my lane now i'm i'm sure i'm sure that zach has never heard but has never heard of this race or run this race because when was the last time that you ran? 2000. I mean, at one point I ran a five minute mile, but that was like a very long time ago. That's fast. Yeah. No, I didn't want to. Like they made me.
因为他们觉得，你在我的车道上，赶紧离开我的车道。现在，我，我确信，我确信 Zack 从来没听过或者跑过这场比赛，因为你上一次跑步是什么时候？2000年。我的意思是，我有一次跑过五分钟一英里，但那是很久以前的事了。那很快。是的。不，我不想。就像他们逼我的一样。
Was it like the police that made you? It was that or it was a five-minute mile or five years in the clink. So I was like – I was on my toes. No, it was – I was in the army 20 years ago. Oh, wow. 25, yeah. That's super fast. Yeah, we're running formation and you don't want to fall out.
是警察逼你的吗？要么是五分钟一英里，要么在号子里蹲五年。所以我当时——我当时如履薄冰。不，那是——我 20 年前在军队里。哦，哇。25年，是的。那超级快。对，我们在队列里跑步，你可不想掉队。
And I remember literally yelling for the back of formation, where's the fire? Because I'm like, why are we running so fast? And then I looked at my watch, and I was like, that was that was the mile mark. And that's five minutes was almost like 505 or something. I was like, Jesus Christ. Yeah, that's very, very fast. So so you and I and I know, Zach, last week, we spent a bunch of time talking about you telling me about your Army past, but I don't know that I know this detail. Did you go to college in the Army or Army then college? No, I was in the college. Well, so I was in college and then I kind of dropped out and I was, you know, did a bunch of stuff, including being in the Army. So it took me 11 years to get through undergrad, like from beginning to end.
我记得我 literalmente 朝着队列后面大喊，着火了吗？因为我在想，为什么我们跑得这么快？然后我看了看表，我想，那是——那是英里标志。那是五分钟，几乎是 505 或别的什么。我当时想，天哪。是的，非常非常快。所以，所以你和我知道的，Zack，上周我们花了很长时间谈论你告诉我你的军队过去，但我不知道我是否知道这个细节。你是在军队里上大学，还是先上大学然后去军队？不，我先上了大学。嗯，所以我在上大学，然后我有点退学了，然后我，你知道，做了一堆事情，包括当兵。所以我花了 11 年才读完本科，从头到尾。
I started in 92 and I ended in 2003. So a lot of people like my age have been working a lot longer than I have. And then a lot of people much younger than me have about the same seniority that I do. It's kind of an odd thing. But yeah, that was just because like I was a really, really crap student and I didn't want to be in school. And I enjoyed the coursework. I just didn't want to do it. I just, you know, I wanted to just like hang out and, and talk to people and have a good time and not do anything. You know, I mean, I mean, that is the best part of university. Yeah. I mean, that, and so that's the thing is
我从 92 年开始，到 2003 年结束。所以很多像我这个年纪的人比我工作的时间长得多。然后很多比我年轻得多的人拥有和我差不多的资历。这有点奇怪。但是，是的，那只是因为我是一个非常非常糟糕的学生，我不想上学。我喜欢课程本身。我只是不想做作业。我只是，你知道，我只想闲逛，和人们聊天，玩得开心，什么也不做。你知道我的意思，我的意思是，那是大学里最好的部分。是的。我的意思是，那，所以这就是问题所在。
that I feel like it's one of those things where I was given just enough freedom to be like, Oh, why don't I just do this all the time? And so then it turned into like my entire existence. And so that was, that was, you know, bad for, for like coursework and stuff. But then eventually, you know, I kind of slept in the mud for three years and I was like, oh yeah, I like want a job job. I don't want to do this. I don't want to do anything like this. So I became super student when I came back as the dean list and all this stuff. So yeah, it was, it was good for me to have that as the sort of break that had the middle
我觉得这是那种给我足够的自由，让我觉得，哦，为什么我不一直这样呢？然后它就成了我的全部存在。所以，这对，你知道的，做功课之类的东西来说是很糟糕的。但后来，你知道，我在泥地里睡了三年，然后我想，哦，对了，我想要一份真正的工作。我不想做这个。我不想做任何类似的事情。所以我回来后成了一个超级学生，上了院长嘉许名单（dean's list）以及所有这些。所以，是的，中间有这样一段休息对我有好处。
because if I just sort of, you know, worked at 7-Eleven or something, I'd probably still be working. I saw that you also you went to UT Austin. Was that both before and after the three years in the mud? Yeah, yeah, yeah. And, you know, I went to UT Austin because I was, you know, from Houston, and I had one parent who lived in Austin. So I knew Austin, I knew I wanted to live there. I liked it a lot. I had friends that from my high school that ended up there. And so I went there for like essentially social reasons. And I just happened to be in a top five computer science department, like, like with zero effort on my end. Like I was in the top 10 of my graduating class. And at the time that meant you had a push button admission to any school in the UT system if you're, if you're a Texas
因为如果我只是，你知道的，在 7-Eleven 之类的地方打工，我可能现在还在打工。我看到你也去了德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校（UT Austin）。那是在泥地里的三年之前还是之后？对，对，对。而且，你知道，我去 UT Austin 是因为我，你知道来自休斯顿，我有一个父母住在奥斯汀。所以我了解奥斯汀，我知道我想住在那里。我很喜欢它。我在高中时的朋友最后也去了那里。所以我去那里基本上是出于社交原因。而且我恰好进入了一个全美前五的计算机科学系，而且，可以说我没有付出任何努力。我在毕业班里名列前茅。当时这意味着如果你是德克萨斯州的毕业高中生，你可以一键录取到 UT 系统的任何学校。
graduating high school student. I literally filled out a postcard and that was it. The fact that I got such a good computer science education was a complete accident, but I'm really thankful for it. I got a really good education there. Were you doing computer
我 literally 填了一张明信片，就这样。我能接受这么好的计算机科学教育完全是个意外，但我对此真的很感激。我在那里受到了非常好的教育。你在去军队之前就在学计算机科学吗？
science before you went into the Army? Did you know when you went to college that's what you wanted to do? Yeah, yeah, absolutely. So I, well, the funny thing is, like, my entire childhood, I wanted to be a physicist. Like, I saw these guys on Nova on, you know, on public TV, and I was like, I want to be one of those guys. I want to be a physicist. I was always obsessed with, like, you know, space and astrophysics and stuff like that and um you know i like read a bunch of
你去上大学的时候就知道那是你想做的吗？对，对，绝对的。所以，我，有趣的是，我整个童年都想成为一名物理学家。我看到公共电视 Nova 节目上的那些家伙，然后我想，我想成为他们中的一员。我想成为一名物理学家。我一直痴迷于，你知道，太空和天体物理学之类的事情，而且，你知道，我读了很多高中时候的物理课本——就出于好奇，对吧，而且我有时会读物理论文，我真的很喜欢它。我记得，在某个时候，我只是在摆弄我的电脑，我想做一点编程，我做的所有事情都与物理有关。但后来当我填写我之前提到的那张小明信片时，在自然科学学院有一张明信片，人文艺术学院有另一张。所以我在自然科学学院的那张上，每个专业都有一个复选框，对吧？所以如果你进入了 UT，你只要选择你的专业，你就会进入这两所学校之一——就像我说的，你选择……我看着复选框，心想，哦，也许我可以学计算机科学。我 literalmente 就想了这么长时间。因为你看，物理学，计算机科学，为什么不呢？这就是我选择这个专业的原因。是的。
physics texts like in high school like just out of curiosity right um and i would read physics papers sometimes i was like really into it and i remember um at some point um i was just messing around with my computer and i wanted to like do a little bit of programming and all the stuff i did was physics related um but then when i was filling out this little postcard that I referred to before like there was a when you're in the college of natural sciences there's one postcard there's a different one for the the college of liberal arts and so I was on the natural sciences one there's a there's a checkbox for each of the majors right so if you get into UT like you just pick your major you get into one of those two schools like like I said you pick the. And I was looking at the checkboxes and I was like, Oh, maybe I'll do computer science. That's literally how long I thought about it. Because look, physics, computer science, why not? And so that's why I did the major that I did. Yeah.
如果你学物理，你最后可能还是会进入计算机科学领域。线性代数接口是标准化的。因此，许多这些人都数学家或物理学家，他们作为工作的一部分，会做大量非常严谨的计算机科学工作。这就是这一行的性质。如果你从事任何应用数学工作，或者如果你现在从事任何物理学工作，你知道，你作为一个程序员的工作，往往比率更高。是的，过去 30 到 40 年里，在几乎所有科学领域中，很大一部分领域转向了计算工作，这真的是一件令人吃惊的事情。
If you went into physics, you probably would have ended up in computer science anyways. linear algebra interface is standardized. And so a lot of those folks are mathematicians or physicists, and they do tons of like really rigorous computer science work as part of their job. It's just the nature of the business. If you work in any kind of applied math, and if you work in any kind of physics these days, you know, your job as a programmer, like more than it's not. Yeah, it's really sort of astonishing how over the past 30 to 40 years in almost all scientific fields, a large chunk of the field has moved to computational work.
但即使对于那些仍然从事湿实验室工作（即仍然在做物理实验等）的领域来说，这项工作越来越也包含计算部分，因为你用这些仪器收集了大量数据，无论你做什么实际实验，都必须进行一些后处理。所以，这就好比，如今，如果你在一条想研究科学的职业道路上，你最终可能不得不做一些编程。好吧，我职业生涯的前半段是在 UT 的一个名为应用研究实验室（Applied Research Laboratories，简称 ARL）的研究实验室度过的。我和一大群人一起研究声纳。他们大多是决定不再做物理学的物理学家。其中一个人说，他之所以做声纳而不是宇宙学，是因为声纳难得多。因为这是一件非常非常困难的事情，因为
But even for the chunk of the field that's still wet lab work where you're still running physical experiments or something, increasingly there's a computational component to that work too because you're collecting so much data with these instruments that you have to do some post-processing of whatever actual experiments you're doing. And so it's like, like these days, like if you're, if you're, if you're in a career path where you want to study the sciences, you're probably going to end up having to do some programming. Yeah. Well, so the first half of my career was at a research lab at UT called Applied Research Laboratories, ARL. And I worked with a whole bunch of people on sonar. And most of them were physicists who decided they didn't want to do physics anymore. One of whom was he said the reason he did sonar instead of cosmology is because sonar is so much harder. Because it's a crazy, crazy hard thing to do uh because
噪声传播是极其嘈杂的，我的意思是声波传播是极其嘈杂的，这就像——你不如把它叫做噪声传播，它全都是在处理噪声。而有时你在宇宙学中可以得到非常好的信号，那些往往是人们关注的领域。但是，是的，这很有趣，比如处理——有一个项目特别有趣，只有我和这个物理学家，对吧？所以我们有一个公共追踪器，用来追踪声纳数据中的信号，而这个旧的实现非常老旧，每个人都害怕去碰它，就像我们要从头开始对它进行全新的实现。我记得有一次，我们显然没有为这个做很多面向对象编程，因为它是数字化的东西，而且我真的不太喜欢——不管怎样，而且，所以他有一次问我，
the noise propagation is is incredibly noisy i mean sound propagation is incredibly noisy and it's like uh you might as well just call it noise propagation it's all dealing with noise uh whereas like you can get really good signals sometimes uh in cosmology and those tend to be the areas people focus on but um yeah it was interesting like dealing with like there was one project in particular it was just me and this physicist right so we had this common tracker uh that we used to track signals and sonar data and with this old implementation it was really crusty everybody's afraid to touch it and like we're going to do a fresh implementation of that from scratch and i remember at one point like we weren't doing a lot of object-oriented programming for this obviously it's numeric stuff and i don't really like oh anyway and um so he was he asked me at one point
什么是虚函数，什么是虚函数？然后我说，哦，我解释了，你知道，你如何拥有多种不同风格的东西，你有一个 switch 语句，它有点摆脱了 switch 语句，它一路贯穿下去，其中存在这些问题，巴拉巴拉。这有点超出他的理解能力了。所以六个月后，他又问，什么是虚函数？我又把整套东西给他解释了一遍。我们去了他的办公室。
what's this virtual what's virtual function what is that and i was like oh and i explained like you know how you'd have like a bunch of different flavors of stuff and you have a switch statement it kind of gets rid of the switch statement and it goes all the way through and there's these problems with it and blah blah and that was a little beyond what he can understand. So six months later, he's like, what is this virtual function? And I did the whole thing. I explained it to him. We went into his office.
我们谈论了它。我把整件事都解释了一遍。大约一年后，这种情况发生了第三次，我说，Jim，我受够了。听着，这就是最后一次。如果你想在将来知道这是什么，记下笔记，或者就继续在无知中生活吧。我记得有一次，同样的事情发生了，但反过来了。
We've talked for it. I explained the whole thing. And then a third time it happened about a year later. And I was like, Jim, I'm done. Like, this is it. This is the last one. Take notes if you want to know what this is in the future or just live in ignorance. And I remember at one point, the same kind of thing happened, but the other way around.
就像我问了一些我有点好奇的事情，但没有记住。我又问了他同样的事情。他说，我以前已经给你解释过了，比如某个物理学的事情，对吧？这真的很有趣，当人们具有技术导向时，无论他们的导向是什么，与他们兴趣领域之外的同样难以理解的事情相比，他们感兴趣的事情很容易留存在他们的脑海中。对。因此，当你专注于一个技术领域而不是另一个技术领域时，即使它是一个相邻的领域，很多时候，也确实缺乏理解。这并不是因为这些事情更难理解。只是你没有朝着做这项工作去理解的方向去努力，你知道，就像那句名言，一起激活的神经元，
Like I asked about something I was kind of curious about, but it didn't stick. And I asked him about the same thing again. He's like, I already explained this to you, like some physics thing, right? And it's really funny how when people are technically oriented, whatever they're oriented towards, the things that they're interested in stick in their heads really easily compared to other equally hard to understand things that are just outside of their interest area. Right. And so when, when you sort of focus on one technical area, not another one, even if it's an adjacent area, a lot of times, like there's, there's a real lack of understanding. And it's not because these things are any harder to understand. So you're just not oriented towards doing that work to understand, you know, it's like that quote, uh, the neurons that fire together,
一起连接。这就像，如果你脑子里已经有了词汇，你知道的？这就像那句名言，一起激活的神经元，一起连接。这就像，如果你脑子里已经有了词汇，学习与此相邻的东西是超级容易的。但如果它在其他领域，当然，它同样困难，但你没有词汇，你没有可以一起激活的神经通路。
wire together. It's like, if you already have the vocabulary in your them, you know? It's like that quote, the neurons that fire together, wire together. It's like, if you already have the vocabulary in your head, you know, learning something that's adjacent to that is super easy. But if it's in some other domain that, sure, it's just as hard, but you don't have the vocabulary, you don't have the wires that can fire together.
所以这只是，我记得，就像我学过的很多东西一样。比如我经历了一个金融阶段，我想成为一名量化分析师。他们只是有词汇，他们拥有的行话，比如份额，股票。你进入期权之类的东西，衍生品，奇异期权。这就像你必须先学习整个词汇表。我记得问我父母，天哪，股票（stock）和份额（share）有什么区别？
So it's just, it's, I remember, it's like so many things I've learned. Like I went through a finance phase where I wanted to be a quant. They just have the vocabulary, the jargon that they have, like share, stock. You get into options and stuff, derivatives, exotic. It's just like you have to learn this whole vocabulary first. I remember asking my parents, man, what's the difference between a stock and a share?
他们不知道。这是一个非常微妙的事情，但并不难。只是，你需要，你需要拥有词汇，才能真正领会如果有人在向你解释什么。如果每四个词里有一个像，我不知道那是什么意思，那么它就记不住了。对。是的。我认为这是一个巨大的问题，对于软件工程教育来说，因为我们有——我的意思是，每个领域都有自己的语言，但我认为这是一个巨大的问题，对于软件工程教育来说，因为我们有——我的意思是，每个领域都有自己的语言，但我认为我们特别是拥有很多行话。而且我认为这变得对我们来说太自然了，以至于我们甚至没有意识到它对新来者是多么难以接近。
They didn't know. It's such a subtle thing, but it's not difficult. It's just, you need, you need to have the vocabulary in order to, to really grok if someone's explaining something to you. If, if every fourth word is like, I don't know what that means, then it's not going to stick. Right. Yeah. And I think that's, that's, that's a, it's a huge problem for a software engineering education because we have, I mean, every field has its own language, but I think that's, that's, that's a, it's a huge problem for a software engineering education because we have, I mean, every field has its own language, but I think we in particular have a lot of jargon. And I think that it becomes so natural to us that we don't even realize how unapproachable it is to, to newcomers.
它的教授方式就像——我刚才在和谁谈论这个，多态性（polymorphism），在学校里，当他们教多态性时，无论是在工程学 201 软件工程 201 中，他们只教运行时多态性（runtime polymorphism），它也被称为动态多态性（dynamic polymorphism），但我认为我列出了大约 10 种不同类型：静态多态性（static polymorphism），也被称为编译时多态性（compile-time polymorphism）、特定即席多态性（ad hoc polymorphism）、参数多态性（parametric polymorphism）、秩多态性（rank polymorphism），诸如此类，没完没了。参数多态性，比如秩多态性。它没完没了。但在学校里，他们提到多态性时，指的仅仅是动态多态性。
And the way it's taught is like, like I was, who was I just talking to this the other day, the polymorphism, like in school, it's's just taught like when they teach polymorphism the unit in whatever engineering 201 software engineering 201 they just teach like runtime polymorphism which also is known as dynamic polymorphism but like there are i think we i listed off like 10 different types static polymorphism also known as compile time polymorphism ad hoc polymorphism parametric polymorphism like rank polymorphism it just goes on and onism, parametric polymorphism, like rank polymorphism. It just goes on and on and on. But in school, they refer to polymorphism and it just refers to dynamic.
但实际上大约有 10 种不同的类型。我从未见过一场演讲讨论伞形世界的概念。你知道，这里有一个伞形术语，多态性以及所有不同的类型。我记得在一次面试中，有人问我，什么是静态多态性？然后我说，我想那就像——我想那就像模板。我记得在一次面试中，有人问我，什么是静态多态性？然后我说，我想那就像——我想那就像模板。他们说，是的。他们说，那为什么它被称为静态多态性？我说，听着，我对模板了解不多。就像，我刚开始学习 C++。不管怎样，这只是，是的，词汇问题是一个问题，因为甚至在教育中，他们教学
But there's like literally 10 different types. And I've never seen a talk that talks about like the umbrella world. You know, here's an umbrella term, polymorphism and all the different types. And I remember in an interview, I got asked once, what is static polymorphism? And then I was like, I think that's like, I think that's like templates. And they remember in an interview, I got asked once, what is static polymorphism? And then I was like, I think that's like, I think that's like templates. And they were like, yeah. And they're like, so why is it called static polymorphism? I was like, listen, I don't know much about templates. Like, I just started learning C++. And anyways, it's just, yeah, the vocabulary problem is, it's a problem because even in education, like they teach
事情的方式非常非常——我甚至不会说它是简化了。我认为教“多态性”这个词却不从一开始就说“好的，我们将专注于这种类型，但根据你使用的语言，还有其他 12 种不同的类型等待你去接触”是有误导性的。我认为这确实是真的，特别鉴于代码中有很多地方需要多态性。代码中很少需要动态多态性，对吧？所以很多时候我看到人们做一些事情，那些——那种中级程序员，我合作过很多这样的程序员，这不是他们的错，而是因为他们来自
things in a very, very, I wouldn't even say it's simplified. Like I think that's misleading to teach the word polymorphism and not start off by saying, okay, we're going to focus on this one type, but like there are 12 different other types that you're going to get to depending on the language you work in. And I think that's really true, especially in the light of the fact that, you know, there is lots of use for polymorphism in code. There's very seldom a need for dynamic polymorphism code right and so like very often i see people do stuff that are you know the kind of intermediate programs i work with a lot of programmers that are like that and it's not a failing of theirs is that they came from
电子工程（EE），他们有点在工作中边干边学。所以这是另一个关于专注的问题，因此当他们看到一种新的编程技术时，他们并没有真正兴趣去深入钻研。那是他们一段时间内着迷的东西。他们会想，哦，别人用了一种不同的方式。我不在乎，对吧？我是用这种方式完成工作的。这才是重要部分。我习惯的方式，我如何完善我已经在进行的任何方向？
double e and they're kind of learning on the job and so it's another it's another question of of focus and so when when they when they see a new programming technique, they aren't like really interested in drilling down on that. That's what they become obsessed with for a while. They're like, oh, someone did it a different way. I don't care, right? I'm getting my work done this way. That's the important part. The way that I'm used to doing it, how can I perfect whatever direction I'm already in?
所以他们已经知道了面向对象（OO）类型的东西。他们编写了大量的虚函数，即使这并不一定是完成工作的正确工具。这就是我刚才提到不喜欢面向对象的原因之一，但我认为这是我们行业中一个非常重要的事情，那就是有那么多人，即使现在你看看网上的课程，比如 C++ 的入门内容，也没有好的 C++ 学习资源。这是另一个话题。但现有的东西中，很多都非常专注于与其他语言制作的其他课程相同的重叠部分。这包括来自 Java 和其他在早期与 C++ 共同进化的语言的大量思想。但那些编写教程的人并不知道 C++ 内部的精英阶层已经完全抛弃了这种范式，而且很少被使用，
So they already know like OO type stuff. They write lots of virtual functions even when that's not necessarily the right tool for the job. And that's one of the things I just mentioned not liking OO, but I think that's like a really big deal in our industry that there's so many people that even now, if you look like on online courses, like introductory stuff for C++ people, there's no good learning resources for C++. That's a different topic. But what there is out there, a lot of it's very focused on the same kind of overlap with, I'm sure, other courses that the same people are making for other languages. And that includes lots of ideas from Java and other things that sort of
是的，除了有时作为其他东西的实现细节，是的，这真的有点——有点不幸，因为我认为很多人
co-evolved with C++ in the early days. But those people writing those tutorials have no idea that the sort of cognoscente within C++ have completely moved away from that paradigm and that's seldom used yeah except sometimes as an implementation detail of something else um yeah it's it's really kind of it's kind of unfortunate because i think a lot of people
都会求助于它，事实上，你知道，在我目前工作的上一个角色中，我做了很多内部培训，并且这是被称为质量团队的一部分，整个想法是为了降低我们代码中的缺陷率，这个团队被称为质量团队。整个想法是为了降低我们代码中的缺陷率，当时的缺陷率有点高。嗯，惨不忍睹的高。太糟糕了，对吧？所以我们试图消除客户现场的崩溃等问题。
reach for that in fact you know the previous role i had at my current job i did a lot of like internal training and and like there was part of this thing called the quality team the whole idea was to like decrease the defect rate in our in our code which was kind of this thing called the quality team. The whole idea was to decrease the defect rate in our code, which was kind of high. Well, tragically high. It was awful, right? And so we were trying to get rid of crashes at customer sites and stuff like this.
因此，当我刚加入团队时，我和老板讨论的事情之一就是，他觉得也许我们可以围绕这个或那个做一些内部培训。你觉得从第一原理（first principles）整理一门课程怎么样，比如如何写好代码，像，你知道的，良好的面向对象技术。然后我说，嗯，真有趣，你这么说，因为根本没有这样的东西。他的脑子有点炸了。但是，你知道，当向他展示新材料、新技术以及它们为什么重要时，他很善于认识到这些，他真的吸收了许多这些经验教训。这真的很酷。所以他并没有
So one of the things my boss and I were talking about when I first joined the team was he was like, maybe we could do some internal training about this or that. What do you think about putting together a course from first principles, like how to write code well, like, you know, good object-oriented techniques. And I was like, well, it's funny that you say that because it's no such thing. His head kind of exploded. But, you know, he was great about like recognizing like new material when I would present to him, like new techniques and why they were important. And he really took a lot of those lessons on board. And that was really cool. So he wasn't
抗拒这一点。他只是感到惊讶。这反映了一种较老的心态，因为当他是日常从业者时，那就是你做事的方式。不幸的是，这种情况一直存在，特别是随着那个时代的人进入管理层。然后他们下面的人正试图以某种方式做事。他们会想，哦，你想做一个带有大型类图之类东西的面向对象东西。所以，这往往会延续这种现象。我有点在等待人们——我知道没有人会读 EOP，但我
like pushing back against that. He was just surprised by it. And that reflects like an older mentality because when he was a day-to-day practitioner, that was kind of the way you did things. And unfortunately, that has persisted, especially as like people that were from that era move into management. And then people below them are trying to do something a certain way. They're like, oh, you want to do an object oriented thing with like some big class diagram or something. And so that, that tends to perpetuate it. And I'm kind of waiting for people to like, I know no one's going to read EOP, but I'm
准备好让人们适应那些——或者采用，我应该说那些那种方法，你知道的。那是《编程要素》（Elements of Programming），Stepanov 的书，这可以说是——它可能不是有史以来关于计算机科学最好的书，但它是最好的一本，它是我读过的唯一一本关于计算机科学或编程的书，我想我们在这个播客中之前讨论过，我并不是那种——等等，你不是说过 SICP 吗？那是结构……你知道什么程序吗？我读过 SICP 的部分内容，《编程要素》是我唯一从头到尾读完的编程书——这两本是我
ready for people to adapt those, those kind of, or adopt, I should say those kind of, those kind of approaches of, you know. And that's, that's Elements of Programming uh stephanov's uh uh book which is sort of the it's it might not be the best book about computer science ever written but it's the best one ever it's the it's the only book on computer science or programming that i've ever read i think we've talked in this podcast before about how i'm not a huge fan of like wait didn't you i thought you said that about sick p which is the structure you know what programs I I've read parts of sick p I've elements of programming is the only programming book I've read all the way through like those are the two
从头读到尾的，而不仅仅是浏览目录。是的，呃，《编程要素》是我唯一读过的一本。我实际上把它通读了两遍。所以我读过很多书，我真的认为《编程要素》是我最感激的一本。事实上，我经常告诉人们，你知道的，现在你可以免费下载 PDF。甚至不需要为此付钱。你甚至不需要手里拿着一棵死树，对吧？你只需要去某个地方下载它就行了。但是如果你能内化第一章的前六页，那就是你所需要的全部。 literalmente，
that I've read from like and not just like skimmed the index of um yeah uh and uh elements of programming is the only one that I've read I've actually read through it twice so I've read lots of them and I really think elements of programming is the one that I've read. I've actually read through it twice. So I've read lots of them, and I really think Elements of Programming is the one that I appreciate the most. And in fact, what I often tell people is, you know, you can get us a free PDF download these days. Like, you don't even need to pay for it. You don't even need to hold around a dead tree in your hands, right? All you need to do is, like, go and download it from somewhere. But if you can internalize the first six pages of the first chapter, that's all you need. Literally,
前六页。如果你能内化这一点，其余的都是这前六页的逻辑延伸。如果你把这前六页应用到涵盖本书其余部分的各种编程风格中，这就是本书其余部分的来源。本书的其余部分非常密集，很难读完。那前六页也很密集，很难读完，但它只有六页。所以这是一个时间投资，我总是告诉人们，虽然我想没有人采纳过，但前六页中的东西太棒了，你知道的，我不知道你们是否有过类似的经历，就像我刚开始时，我会听说某种技术，我会想，我要找个借口在我的代码中使用它，
the first six pages. If you can internalize that, the rest of it is logical extension of that first six pages. If you apply those first six pages to all these kinds of programming styles that are covering the rest of the book, that's where the rest of the book comes from. And the rest of the book is very dense and hard to get through. That first six pages is also dense and hard to get through, but it's only six pages. So it's you know a time investment i always tell people that i don't think i've had any takers but i mean the stuff in that first six pages is so good you know i don't know if you guys had a similar experience of like you know when i was first starting out i would hear about some technique and i would like be like i'm going to find an excuse to use my code
因为这很有趣，我要看看这是否管用，对吧？所以你会故意用错误的方式来做事情，看看它是如何工作的。然后你会想，啊，它管用了，或者没管用。然后你就会调整，对吧？所以有许多许多不同风格的东西，比如，你知道的，只是文本约定，比如，你知道的，大括号放在哪里。在我职业生涯的进程中，我一次又一次地尝试了所有这些不同的东西，进行不同的实验。而我唯一的建议是，一旦我内化了它，我 literalmente 从未回头看，也从未改变过，甚至当有新数据引入给我时，也就是第一章的前六页。我的意思是，它们真的是，
because that's interesting i'm gonna see if that works right and so you do things like kind of like the wrong way on purpose to see how it worked. And then you're like, ah, it works or it didn't. And you kind of adapt, right? So there have been many, many different styles of like things from like, you know, just texting, textual conventions like, you know, where you put hanging braces. All these different things I've tried over the course of my career over and over again, different experiments. And the only bit of advice that I have, once I internalized it, I literally never looked back or never changed, even when I had new data introduced to me as those first six pages of that first chapter. I mean, they're really,
我认为，无可挑剔。那么核心的教训是什么？因此，一些核心教训是人们已经相当好理解的事情，对吧？所以其中之一是，你知道，你想为了重用而编写代码。这意味着泛型地编写代码。有很多关于定义什么应该在接口中、什么不应该在接口中的内容。我认为这是人们没有很好吸收的部分。特别是，你知道，他们定义了什么是操作基底（basis of operations）。“基底”这个名字借用了 N 空间中“基向量”的类比，对吧？
I think, unassailable. What are the key lessons to take away from? So some of the key lessons are things that people already pretty well understand, right? So one of the things is, you know, you want to write things for reuse. And that means like writing things generically. There's lots of things about like defining what should and should not be in interfaces. And this is the part that I think people don't take on board as well. One thing in particular is that, you know, they define what a basis of operations is. A basis takes its name as analogy to like basis vectors in an N space, right?
所以你有 N 个正交归一的基向量，然后这就定义了一个 N 空间。同样地，你可以在你的类型上定义 n 个操作。只要定义了类型上的这 n 个操作，你就可以通过这些操作的某些组合来做该类型能够做的任何事情。只要你能使用这些操作高效地达到你想要的任何行为，这就是正确的，或者抱歉，这些操作，这就是正确的操作集合。你不需要比这更多的操作，因为这会增加
So you have N basis vectors that are orthonormal, and then that defines an N space. Similarly, you can define n operations on your type. And as long as those n operations on the type are defined, you can do anything that that type is capable of just with some combination of those. And as long as you can efficiently get to any behavior you want to using those types, and that's the right, or sorry, those operations, that's the right set of operations. And you don't want any more operations than that because that increases
测试负担、表面积、造成各种混乱，诸如此类的事情。所以你希望它小，但又不能太小，你希望它是高效的，然后只要存在这一点，你就可以做任何其他事情。你不想添加任何其他事情的原因是，如果你编写自由函数而不是编写新的成员，那么当其他某个类型——你有你的类型 T，其他某个类型 U，你在未来编写它，并且它在某些方面与类型 T 所做的事情具有非常相似的语义时。那么突然之间，你编写的那个自由函数，你就可以直接使用它并且它能工作，对吧？这背后的理念与这两个人中的同一个所编写的算法库背后的理念相同，对吧？Alex Stepanov，
test burden surface area it creates confusion all kinds of stuff like that so you want it to be small but not too small you want to be efficient and then as long as that exists you can do anything else and the reason you don't want to add anything else is because if you write free functions instead of writing a new member, then when some other type, you've got your type T, some other type U, you write it in the future, and it has very similar semantics in some aspect of what this type T did. Then all of a sudden that free function you wrote, you can just use it and it works, right? This is the same idea behind the algorithms library by one of the same two people, right? Alex Stepanov,
Paul McJones 是另一个人。那里的想法就像，我们要编写所有这些算法，而不是把算法挂在所有这些不同的数据结构上，比如 vector、map 等等。我认为这是做事情的正确方式。事实上，我真的认为在经历了将一个新的类似容器的东西添加到标准库（也就是 flat_map）的过程之后，
Paul McJones being the other one. The idea there was like, we're going to write all these algorithms and not like hang an algorithm off of all these different data structures like vector and map and so on. And I think that's the right way to do things. And in fact, I really think after going, after having gone through the process of adding a new container-like thing to the standard library, which is flat map,
我意识到我再也不想那样做了。我也不希望其他人再这样做，因为我认为像 flat_map 这样的东西正确的做法——好吧，让我倒退一下。所以我在特别谈论 flat_map，因为它只是克隆了 map 的大部分接口，它有像 insert 这样的东西，它有 emplace，它有方括号操作符，它有 try_emplace，它有巴拉巴拉，它有所有这些不同的东西，对吧？如果你把它归结起来，它只是 try_emplace——
I realized that I don't ever want to do that again. I don't want anyone else to have to do that again either because I think the right thing for something like flat map – well, let me back up. So what I'm talking about in particular is flat map, because it's just cloning most of the interface of map it has things like insert it has in place it has the square bracket operator it has try in place it has blah blah has all these different things right and if you boil it down it's just try in place like
literally 你可以编写 try_emplace，而所有其他的——在它们的描述中，它们会说，我们将执行 try_emplace，如果这不起作用，那么我们将创建一个新对象，然后我们将尝试 emplace，这就是方括号的大致定义，对吧，等等。诸如此类，所有其他种类的插入都只是 try_emplace 的某种排列。这就引出了一个问题：如果我们有 map、flat_map、multi-map、flat_multi-map（我想无序的那些不太一样）。但如果我们对树状容器拥有这一点，即使你在 flat_map 的情况下拥有扁平化的树，为什么我们不能只拥有一个执行插入的自由函数，
literally you can write try in place and all the others like in their in their description they say like we're going to do try and place and if that doesn't work then we're going to create a new object and then we're going to try and place that's what square bracket is defined as like roughly right um and so on and so forth like all the other kind of inserts are just some permutation of try and place so that begs the question if we have map, flat map, multi-map, flat multi-map, I guess the own order ones don't quite work the same. But if we have that for the tree-like containers, even if you have a flattened tree in the case of flat map, why don't we have just like a free function that does insert,
一个根据 try_emplace 执行的函数？然后如果你想制作你自己的类似 map 的类型，你只需要定义大约 10 到 12 个函数，诸如此类，而不是 literalmente，我认为对于 std::vector（它要小得多），我认为有 64 个成员。是的，它们大多数是 emplace、push_back 或类似的形式。是的，完全正确，是的。所以如果你有 emplace 和 emplace push_back 或者，是的，完全正确，是的。所以如果你有 emplace 和 emplace_back
that does in terms of try and place? And then if you want to make your own map-like type, you only have to define like, you know, 10, 12 functions, something like that, instead of like literally, I think for std vector, which is much smaller, I think there was 64 members. Yeah, and most of them are some form of in place, push back, or yeah. Yeah, exactly, yeah. So if you had in place and in place push back or yeah yeah exactly yeah so if you had in place and in place back
嗯，这就是你真正需要的全部，对吧？你甚至可以在 emplace 内部有一个分支，说明它在末尾并做正确的事情，对吧？所以你知道，那是——那是让你付出一些效率代价的泛化，所以也许你不想要那样，但你也可以做到这一点。长话短说，我认为人们应该编写更多——容器，因为比方说你有 vector、static_vector 和 dynamic（或者不是 dynamic vector，我在说什么？
um you know that that's all you really need right you can even have a branch inside of in place that tells that it's at the back and it does the right thing right so you know that's that's that's a generalization that that costs you some efficiency so maybe you don't want that but but you could get there too so the long and short of it is i think people should be writing more um containers because like let's say you've got vector and static vector and dynamic or not dynamic vector what am i trying to say um small vector right that's what i'm trying to say so small vectors along with a small buffer optimization then then it goes to the heap if it can't if it can't do stuff there you really want to be able to write all those
小 vector，对吧？这就是我想说的）所以小 vector 连同小缓冲区优化（small buffer optimization），然后如果它不能在那里做事情，它就会进入堆。你真的希望能够非常方便地编写所有这些，
really conveniently right um because there's no reason why you shouldn't have a vector-like interface for any of these things. But people don't have a convenient way of doing that. They have to repeat those 64 different ways of doing stuff. So I think it's a big, fat bummer. And David Stone, actually, he's another committee member. He has a project that he's been working on for a little while to try to make the abstractions for all of the – we have sort of these categories of containers in the standard. So the vector-like ones are sequence containers,
对吧？因为没有理由你不应该为任何这些东西拥有一个类似 vector 的接口。但人们没有一种方便的方法来做到这一点。他们必须重复那 64 种不同的做事方式。所以我认为这是一个大大的遗憾。事实上，David Stone 是另一个委员会成员。他有一个项目，他一直在致力于尝试为所有这些——我们在标准中有这些容器类别。因此，类 vector 的容器是序列容器（sequence containers），
and the node-based containers are – what do we call those? We call them associative containers. So those are what we call the associated containers so those are things like map and set and so forth so he's tried to do exactly what i just talked about right like figuring out what that small basis is and let's make free functions for everything else and he says he's still not happy with it he's been he's been working on it for a while but i think that kind of thing really if people did more of that, then we would be better off. So the classic example to me is, and this is a real question I had at work. Like someone said, well, I got this string view and it's got like find last not of or something. So one of these algorithms that hangs off of strings and string views.
而基于节点的容器是——我们叫它们什么？我们称它们为关联容器（associative containers）。所以这些就是我们所说的关联容器，比如 map 和 set 等等。所以他试图做我刚才谈论的事情，对吧——弄清楚那个小的基底是什么，并为其他一切制作自由函数。他说他仍然对它不满意。他一直在研究它，但我认为这种事情，如果人们做更多这样的事情，那么我们的情况就会更好。对我来说，经典的例子是，这也是我在工作中遇到的一个真实问题。就像有人说，嗯，我有了这个 string_view，它有一些诸如 find_last_not_of 之类的东西。所以这些算法之一是挂在 string 和 string_view 上的。
And he said, but I've got a span sometimes. Sometimes I've got a string view. Like, how do I do this? And I said, well, you have to construct a string view from the span in order to get that algorithm. It's dumb, but that's what you have to do. And that's such an unsatisfying answer. Like, why isn't that an algorithm, right? And why don't we have just a set
他说，但有时我有一个 span。有时我有一个 string_view。我该怎么做？我说，嗯，你必须从 span 构造一个 string_view 才能获得该算法。这很蠢，但这就是你必须做的。这是一个非常令人不满意的答案。为什么这不是一个算法，对吧？为什么我们不能只拥有一套
of string algorithms that does string stuff, right? I think that could work really nicely. Yeah. It's, I think once you learn more about generic programming, you start to become aware of the cost of adding a new type
做字符串事情的字符串算法，对吧？我认为这会运作得很好。是的，我认为一旦你更多地了解了泛型编程，你就会开始意识到添加新类型的成本，
and of added complexity in the interface of a type. And it's like any time I either work around the committee that somebody shows me their proposal for some new class does some great thing. And it's got like a lot of knobs and bells and whistles. My like first gut reaction is always like, all right, let's like take all those knobs and bells and whistles and like take them out. And like, let's just get down to like, what are the core basis operations of this thing? And it's because anytime that we add additional complexity that we don't need,
以及增加类型接口复杂性的成本。这就像任何时候我要么在委员会周围工作，要么有人向我展示他们关于某个新类的提案，该提案做了一些很棒的事情，并且有很多旋钮、铃铛和口哨。我的第一直觉总是像，好的，让我们把所有那些旋钮、铃铛和口哨拿掉。然后，让我们回归到——这个东西的核心基底操作是什么？这是因为任何时候我们增加不需要的额外复杂性时，
one, it's typically a mistake that we can't come back and undo later. But we end up in this world where we have things like string that have dozens of different operations on it. And when we wanted to make another string-like thing, string view, we had no choice but to make string view have all those same operations as well. And I think that that's a much worse world than the world that we could have lived in where we could have, we could have had some string algorithms and maybe we could have introduced some sort of concept for string types. And we could have had, um, some like string view would have looked a lot more like span.
第一，这通常是一个我们以后无法回退和撤销的错误。但我们最终身处这样一个世界，在这个世界里，像 string 这样的东西有几十种不同的操作。当我们要制作另一个类似 string 的东西，即 string view 时，我们别无选择，只能让 string view 也拥有所有这些相同的操作。我认为，与我们本可以生活的那个世界相比，这是一个糟糕得多的世界。在那个世界里，我们可以有一些 string 算法，也许我们可以为 string 类型引入某种概念。我们本可以拥有……嗯，某种类似 string view 的东西，它看起来会更像 span。
It would have been a very simple thing. And it would have been possible to have like a string, a string like concept where you could just have your own string thing just satisfy that concept. In the same vein as that, you know, when we added – I know a lot of people are happy that we're finally getting unstud string in the last couple of standards we've gotten, like contain, start with, and ends with. And I complained so loudly in LEWG that we should not be adding these. Like these are algorithms that we should have with those names that work with strings and they said but they don't work for char star i'm so let's make an overload that works with char star this is this is not hard to do we can add
那将会是一件非常简单的事情。并且，拥有一种类似 string 的概念将是可能的，在这里，你只需让自己的 string 东西满足该概念即可。顺便便提一下，你知道，当我们添加——我知道很多人很高兴我们在过去的几个标准中终于得到了 std::string 的一些功能，比如 contain、starts_with 和 ends_with。我在 LEWG 里大声抱怨过我们不应该添加这些。就像这些是我们应该针对字符串拥有的、适用于字符串的算法一样，他们却说，但是它们不适用于 char star，所以让我们制作一个适用于 char star 的重载吧。这并不难做到，我们可以添加
that right and i was like even if we even if we start a new um section of the library like a sub name space or or some kind of naming convention we have all the string algorithms over here in their own little spot that beats having like to add this to string and then string view and then whatever else comes along later. Because, you know, sometimes people are going to want to have their own string-like thing. And it doesn't have to be necessarily interoperable
对吧。我当时觉得，即使我们开启了库的一个新部分，比如子命名空间或某种命名规范，把所有的 string 算法都放在它们自己的小地方里，也比必须把这个添加到 string，然后添加到 string view，再添加到以后出现的任何其他东西要好。因为，你知道，有时人们会想要拥有他们自己的类似 string 的东西。而且它不一定非要与
with string or string view. And they just can't make it work with generic code without repeating all this API. And I think that's a huge problem. We want people to write quick and dirty code that's reusable by everybody as much as they can, right? Because the testing burden for writing complicated things is so high that we just don't do it, right? And so you have this untested stuff, or you have stuff that just doesn't work in a generic context, because either I was going to have to write these extra interfaces and test them, but since I don't want to do that, I just don't write them or I don't test them. Neither one of those is a very good
string 或 string view 互操作。他们只是无法在不重复所有这些 API 的情况下让它与泛型代码一起工作。我认为这是一个巨大的问题。我们希望人们能够编写尽可能多地被所有人复用的快速且简单的代码，对吧？因为编写复杂东西的测试负担太高了，以至于我们根本不去做，对吧？所以你会有这些未经测试的东西，或者有那些在泛型上下文中根本无法工作的代码，因为要么我必须编写这些额外的接口并测试它们，但既然我不想这样做，我就干脆不写或不测试它们。这两种都不是什么好
answer. This is why this Boost library has steel interfaces, and hopefully we're going to standardize this, but I have a class in there or a template in there that will let you write iterators much more simply than repeating all thei of an iterator because what i found was uh i was working on this other library that needed iterators all over the place for views and ranges of things and every time i wrote an iterator i made like a subtle mistake and i started realizing i was i was doing it a lot and so i was like why i should have glue for this this should be easy and so i think we should try to if we're going to define interfaces that everyone needs to use, then we should define either really good glue that helps them generate that code, or we should define them in such a minimal way that they don't need to
答案。这就是为什么这个 Boost 库拥有精妙的接口，希望我们能够将其实际标准化，但我在那里有一个类或模板，可以让你编写迭代器，比重复迭代器的所有……要简单得多。因为我发现——嗯，我正在开发另一个库，它在视图和各种范围（ranges）中到处都需要迭代器，每当我编写一个迭代器时，我都会犯一些微小的错误，我开始意识到我经常这样做，所以我想，为什么我应该为此准备胶水代码（glue），这应该很简单。因此，我认为我们应该尝试，如果我们要定义人人都需要使用的接口，那么我们要么应该定义真正好的胶水代码来帮助他们生成该代码，要么我们应该以极度最小化的方式定义它们，使他们不需要
generate that code. Because all of these bugs that we're introducing, you know, there's something like, I think that the industry standard when I learned this back in school was something like, for every 100 lines of code, you've got a bug and that's considered to be a good defect rate. I'm talking about the first draft. The first time you write some code, people have done some testing and stuff. They check it in
生成该代码。因为我们引入的所有这些 bug——你知道，有那么个说法，我认为我在学校学到这个的时候，行业标准大约是，每 100 行代码就会有一个 bug，这被认为是一个不错的缺陷率。我说的是初稿。你第一次写一些代码，人们做了一些测试之类的。他们将其签入
and then from that stage, we're not even talking about just I banged out some bullshit. This is actually I've done my due diligence and I've still got basically a bug every 100 lines. So if you can reduce the number of lines people write, you reduce the defect rate.
然后从那个阶段开始，我们甚至不只是在讨论我随手写的一堆烂代码。这实际上是我已经尽职尽责了，但基本上每 100 行代码仍然有一个 bug。因此，如果你能减少人们编写的代码行数，你就能降低缺陷率。
It's sort of an inherent thing to writing code, it seems. It doesn't seem to depend on the language or anything. But right now we have a lot of things, particularly in the standard, that don't lend themselves to reuse that way. I mean, I know very, very few people have ever written an iterator like and and you know whenever whenever
这似乎是编写代码的一种固有特性。它似乎不依赖于语言或任何东西。但现在我们有很多东西，特别是在标准库中，不利于这种复用。我的意思是，我知道极少数人曾经编写过迭代器，而且你知道，每当
i have had to write an iterator i typically only write the operations that i am going that i know i will need to use in my code yep and it's simply because like, if I need to show the code to somebody else, I want it to be as like short as possible. Yeah. And the funny thing is like, that will not fly with the ranges. Right. Because the ranges are actually like concepts.
我不得不编写迭代器时，我通常只编写我知道在我的代码中需要使用的那些操作。是的，这很简单，因为如果我需要把代码展示给别人，我希望它尽可能简短。是的。有趣的是，这在 ranges 中行不通。对吧？因为 ranges 实际上就像是概念（concepts）。
Yeah, I know. It's a real problem for me. Yeah. Well, you know, in a similar vein, you know, there's one of the things that we spend a lot of time talking about when we're designing new library facilities is I think the questions of like default constructability and the conversions that a type has comes up a ton and like default constructability whether or not your thing can be default constructed is usually like this huge question for your type because if it can't be default constructed then there's a lot of context especially in generic code where your thing isn't going to be able to be used but if it does you know if you are going to make a default constructed,
是的，我知道。这对我来说是个真正的难题。是的。嗯，你知道，同理，你知道，我们在设计新的库功能时花费大量时间讨论的事情之一，我认为像默认构造性（default constructability）以及类型具有的转换这样的问题被提及了无数次。比如默认构造性，你的东西是否可以被默认构造，通常对你的类型来说是一个巨大的问题，因为如果它不能被默认构造，那么在很多上下文中，特别是在泛型代码中，你的东西将无法使用。但是如果你这样做了，你知道，如果你要制作一个可默认构造的，
does your thing have some sort of null state or empty state? And if so, what does that do to the invariance of the rest of your thing? And likewise for conversions, this question of when does your thing convert and are those conversions implicit or explicit is a huge question in the design of almost any type. Especially when there's, I think on the committee, we tend to like anything that has potential for performance loss to be explicit. Yeah. Yeah. So I remember saying to a bunch of people at a committee meeting, we're just hanging out after, you know, sessions.
你的东西是否有某种空状态（null state）或空值状态（empty state）？如果是这样，这对你的其余代码的不变式（invariants）有什么影响？同样对于转换，你的东西何时转换，这些转换是隐式的还是显式的，这个问题几乎在任何类型的设计中都是一个巨大的问题。特别是在委员会里，我认为我们倾向于将任何具有潜在性能损失的东西设为显式的。是的。是的。所以我记得在委员会会议上对许多人说过，我们只是在会议结束后聚在一起闲聊。
And I said, I think I literally said implicit conversions are evil because like so many people write so many of them and they cause all kinds of headaches. And then Bjarne who happened to be, said, no, they're not evil. You just need to make sure that an implicit conversion converts between something that you're converting from and something you're converting to, where the to and from types are essentially the same thing. And then it's natural and normal and everybody can reason about it. So like converting between a float and a double should be implicit for that reason, for instance, right? It's questionable, and I think other languages have made a different decision. I think I like the decision more that an integral value and a floating point value
我当时说，我字面意思是隐式转换是邪恶的，因为有太多人编写了太多隐式转换，它们引发了各种各样的头疼问题。然后恰好在场的 Bjarne 说，不，它们并不邪恶。你只需要确保隐式转换在你要转换的源类型和目标类型之间进行转换，其中目标类型和源类型本质上是同一种东西。然后它就是自然而然的、正常的，每个人都可以对其进行推理。所以，比如在 float 和 double 之间进行转换出于这个原因应该是隐式的，对吧？这是值得商榷的，我认为其他语言做出了不同的决定。我认为我更喜欢这样的决定，即整型值和浮点值
maybe should not be interconvertible, right? But that's a default we have from C. And I think the question of whether something is default constructible, and by the way, this is another one of the first six pages of EOP, is the notion of regularity, right? Like you have all these operations that are like, if you're like an int, you're regular, and that allows you to reason about your code.
也许不应该是可以互换转换的，对吧？但这又是我们从 C 语言继承下来的默认设定。我认为某物是否可默认构造的问题——顺便说一句，这也是 EOP（《C++ Element of Programming》）前六页的另一个内容——就是正则性（regularity）的概念，对吧？就像你拥有所有这些操作，如果你像一个 int 一样，你就是正则的，这能让你对代码进行推理。
And in particular, to do local reasoning about your code, because you don't have to worry about things like the semantics of the code, plus where do all these guys live in memory? This one over here, that one over there. Well, she lives over here and he lives over there. I don't know if the alias to the same thing. Like local reasoning is enabled by saying well i can see the values and i see how they're used and the semantics of the the
特别是，对你的代码进行局部推理（local reasoning），因为你不必担心代码语义之类的事情，再加上这些家伙在内存中都住在哪里？这个在这里，那个在那里。嗯，她住在里这，他住在那里。我不知道它们是否别名到同一个东西。局部推理之所以成为可能，是因为你可以说，嗯，我可以看到这些值，我可以看到它们是如何被使用的，我所做的操作的语义就是我唯一需要关心的，我必须关心生命周期和诸如此类的其他事情。嗯，
operations that i'm doing is all i have to care about i have to care about lifetime and other things like this um so the reason that default constructability is in there even though it's not actually required for any of the algorithms in the STL like everything everything else in in regular is actually required to to operate with everything in the STL and so you can see why that's a useful definition for someone who's going to write something like the STL so someone asked Alex Stepanov one time like why is that in there it's not it's not required unlike everything else he He said, well, it sure is convenient. And to me, that's enough because, you know, part of that first six pages, he says, like, you know, you need to not just write, like, a basis of operations that, like, could work sometime. And the example he gives is, like, what if you have a mathy kind of type, right?
所以默认构造性之所以包含在里面，尽管 STL 中的任何算法实际上并不强制要求它——实际上 STL 中的一切其他东西都确实要求能够与 STL 中的一切协同工作——所以你可以理解为什么对于将要编写像 STL 这样东西的人来说，这是一个有用的定义。所以有人曾问过 Alex Stepanov，为什么这个在里面？它不像其他所有东西那样是必需的。他说，嗯，它确实很方便。对我来说，这就足够了，因为，你知道，作为那前六页的一部分，他说，像，你知道，你不仅需要编写一组在某些时候可以工作的操作基础。他给出的例子是，比如，如果你有一种数学类型的类型，对吧？
So it does arithmetic operations. Well, you could provide, like, minus but not plus, like binary minus but not binary plus. And you could say, well, you just negate it. Yeah, it's in there, right? So, yeah, okay, you could do that, but it's incredibly inconvenient. It's a type that you want to use for math, so you should be able to do that. And I think default constructability goes under the same rubric, like is it convenient? And if not, then why not?
所以它做算术运算。嗯，你可以提供，比如减号而不是加号，比如二元减号而不是二元加号。你可以说，嗯，你只需对其取负就行了。是的，它在里面，对吧？所以，好吧，你可以这样做，但这极其不方便。它是一种你想用于数学的类型，所以你应该能够做到这一点。我认为默认构造性也属于同一范畴，就像它方便吗？如果不是，那为什么不呢？
So I think there are some types that really you cannot default construct because it doesn't make sense, right? So something like a lock, I know there are patterns that people come up with where like they want a default constructed lock. But I think really the 99.9% cases, the reason I'm constructing a lock is so that in its lifetime, it holds the lock and that's what it's for and it shouldn't do anything else. So I think that that should be not default constructable. But I think most things we should definitely have regularity as part of them. And in particular, since that statement from Stepanoff, we now have move semantics in the language. Because that was an old interview, I think.
所以我认为有些类型确实无法默认构造，因为这没有意义，对吧？所以像锁（lock）这样的东西，我知道人们想出了一些模式，比如他们想要一个可默认构造的锁。但我认为 99.9% 的情况下，我构造锁的原因是它在其生命周期内持有该锁，这就是它的用途，它不应该做任何其他事情。所以我认为那不应该是可默认构造的。但我认为对于大多数事情，我们绝对应该将正则性作为它们的一部分。特别是，自从 Stepanov 那个发言以来，我们现在语言中有了移动语义（move semantics）。因为那是一个很古老的访谈，我想。
But now the argument to me is both convenience, the Stepanoff answer, but my new answer is, can you move this thing? If you can't move it, then yeah, let's talk about it, whether it's default construct. But if you can move it, I don't want to hear this, it changes the invariance because the invariance are already that way. Like you have a move from state that you have to reason about. We don't have, unfortunately, a destroying move operation in C++ where when you move something, it's gone. I don't have to reason about it anymore. I think that's a better semantic, but we don't have that. The fact that I've got this thing around and I have to have that in a set of things that I'm reasoning about when I look at the value because it was moved from, that means that I have to be able to reason about that before
但现在对我来说，论点既有便利性（Stepanov 的回答），也有我的新答案：你能移动这个东西吗？如果你不能移动它，那么好吧，我们来讨论它是否可默认构造。但如果你能移动它，我不想听这种“它改变了不变式”的说法，因为不变式本来就是那样的。就像你有一个必须对其进行推理的移后状态（move from state）。不幸的是，在 C++ 中我们没有销毁移动操作（destroying move operation），即当你移动某物时，它就消失了。我不再需要对其进行推理。我认为那是更好的语义，但我们没有。事实上，这个东西还在我身边，当我看着这个值时，我必须把它放在我正在推理的一组事物中，因为它被移动过了，这意味着我也必须能够在这之前
it's got a value as well. So I don't think there's anything wrong or messy about that. I don't think it weakens invariance in the way that people claim that it does. I just don't think it's a big deal. Yeah, I tend to agree. Yeah. And I've had the same argument with a lot of people, a lot of very smart people. And in some case, I'm the only one in the discussion that thinks this. And so I know it's not a popular opinion amongst especially a lot of the sort of thought leaders in the community, but I really think it's the right answer. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对具有该值的状态进行推理。所以我不认为这有什么不对或混乱的地方。我不认为它以人们声称的那样削弱了不变式。我只是觉得这不是什么大不了的事。是的，我倾向于同意。是的。我和很多人争论过这个问题，很多非常聪明的人。在某些情况下，我是讨论中唯一这样想的人。所以我知道这不是一个受欢迎的观点，尤其是在社区里的许多思想领袖当中，但我真的认为这是正确的答案。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并度过美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。